c'est toujours leur de barbarie ça avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
qu'est ce qui se passe capillairement on
est sur quoi laquelle projet puis armand
n'y a pas de projet c'est n'importe quoi
ce illégal
j'aime beaucoup moi beaucoup ah ouais
ouais ouais c'est une vanne derrière on
en a une mais non non franchement j'aime
bien c'est vrai que question va faire tu
t'es sur un carré plongeant tuba coupe
et on va essayer et réessayer je dois
laisser pousser pour un rôle et voilà
c'est ce qui se passe et c'est quoi là
et on va reprendre la planète des singes
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti top
gfr
jusqu'à quand
le connais on a pris notre bouche
ensemble après le tennis
alors eh ben et alors j'ai pris j'ai
failli vous tromper que le tai chi douce
ah oui nous
bruno c'est vraiment la forme d'une
bouteille de tahiti douche
oui oui parce qu'il a big man et hui
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
tu vas être le produit
c'est pas possible
[Applaudissements]
là
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]